قرر البرلمان الاوروبي حسمى دعم مالي
مخصصه من الاتحاد الاوروبي لاوكرانيا تبلغ
قيمتها 18 مليار يورو في خطه ما زالت
المجر تعرقل تطبيقها واكدت انها تعارض
استدانه التكتل بشكل مشترك لتمويل حزمه
المساعدات وكشفت المجر انها سترسل مساعدات
ماليه لاوكرانيا بقيمه 187 مليون يورو
الخارجيه المجاريه اعلنت ايضا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي قرر اعفاء المجر من تحديد سقف
اسعار النفط الروسيه في المقابل اثار رئيس
وزراء المجر فيكتور قربان غضب ادوار
الجوار من خلال ارتداء وشاحن عليه خريطه
لبلاده تعود الى ما قبل الحرب العالميه
الاولى بما في ذلك اجزاء جرى ضمها الى
النمسا وسلوفاكيا ورومانيا وكرواتيا
واوكرانيا وفقا لصحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
وتعد المجال الاكثر تقاربا مع موسكو من
بين بلدان الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]